THE FOREIGN INVASION.
THE SYRIAN CIVIL WAR BEGAN IN
2011 AND HAS CLAIMED NEARLY A
HALF MILLION LIVES.
>>> WELL, AS JOHN MENTIONED
EARLIER IN THE SHOW, PRESIDENT
TRUMP ARRIVED HERE IN SINGAPORE
AFTER LEAVING THE G-7 ECONOMIC
SUMMIT IN CANADA.
AND TO SAY THAT HE SHOOK THINGS
UP THERE WOULD BE WELL AN
UNDERSTATEMENT.
NOT LONG AFTER THE PRESIDENT
DEPARTED, HIS TOP TRADE ADVISOR
ACCUSED CANADA OF STABBING THE
U.S. IN THE BACK.
HERE'S CORRESPONDENT ELLISON
BARBER.
>> ON JULY 1ST, CANADA SAYS IT
WILL IMPOSE ROUGHLY 12.8 BILLION
DOLLARS WORTH OF RETALIATORY
TARIFFS ON THE U.S., TAXES ON
GOODS IN TWO LISTS, VARIATION OF
PRODUCTS MADE FROM STEEL, IRON,
ALUMINIUM, ITEMS MANY AMERICANS
HAVE AT HOME, YOGURT, CHOCOLATE,
MAPLE SYRUP, COFFEE, WHISKEYS,
PLAYING CARDS, TOILET PAPER,
BALLPOINT PENS.
>> I DON'T WANT TO HURT AMERICAN
WORKERS.
THEY ARE OUR NEIGHBORS.
THEY ARE OUR FRIENDS.
MY JOB IS TO STAND UP FOR
CANADIAN WORKERS.
>> THE PRIME MINISTER TRUDEAU
SAYS HE DOES NOT WANT TO IMPOSE
THE TARIFFS BUT CLAIMS HE HAS NO
CHOICE.
>> THE ADMINISTRATION'S CHOICE
TO IMPOSE ILLEGAL AND
UNACCEPTABLE TARIFFS
ILLEGITIMATE AND UNACCEPTABLE
TARIFFS TO CANADIAN STEELWORKERS
AND AUTOWORKERS, MUST BE MET
WITH AN EQUIVALENT RESPONSE.
>> THAT NEWS CONFERENCE ENRAGED
THE PRESIDENT AND HIS
ADMINISTRATION.
THEY SAY CANADA HAS WRONGED THE
U.S. ON TRADE FOR YEARS, THAT
THE U.S.'S STEEL AND ALUMINIUM
TARIFFS ON CANADA, MEXICO AND
THE EUROPEAN UNION ARE A
NATIONAL SECURITY NECESSITY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAYS THE U.S. IS
NOW LOOKING AT ADDING MORE
TARIFFS, THIS TIME ON AUTOMOBILE
IMPORTS.
>> THERE'S A SPECIAL PLACE IN
HELL FOR ANY FOREIGN LEADER THAT
ENGAGES IN BAD FAITH DIPLOMACY
WITH PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP AND
THEN TRIES TO STAB HIM IN THE
BACK ON THE WAY OUT THE DOOR.
I WILL TELL YOU THIS, TO MY
FRIENDS IN CANADA, THAT WAS ONE
OF THE WORST POLITICAL
MISCALCULATIONS OF THE CANADIAN
LEADER IN MODERN CANADIAN
HISTORY.
>> ONE REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN
SAYS THE PRESIDENT ISN'T WRONG
WHEN IT COMES TO SOME OF HIS
COMPLAINTS ON TRADE, BUT HE'S
CONCERNED ABOUT A TRADE WAR.
>> IN MY DISTRICT I HEAR FROM
FARMERS, I HEAR FROM HEAVY
EQUIPMENT MANUFACTURERS, ALL OF
THEM HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT TARIFFS
SPECIFICALLY WITH CANADA.
HE NEEDS TO BE STRONG IN GETTING
A BETTER DEAL, BUT MAKING SURE
TOO THAT WE DON'T GET INTO A
FULL-FLEDGED TRADE WAR.
TARIFFS COULD POSSIBLY LEAD US
THERE.
>> THERE ARE ALSO QUESTIONS
ABOUT WHAT THIS COULD MEAN FOR
TALKS.
U.S. SECRETARY OF COMMERCE
PREVIOUSLY SAID THE TALKS WERE
SEPARATE FROM TARIFFS.
BUT ON SATURDAY CANADA'S FOREIGN